he's sitting Indian style oh he's got a
knife Flashlight Flashlight
Flashlight hold on boys
yep right here
stop
[Music]
up we want to get you out of
there hand up show us your
hands Nikki
pull
level let's Let the Smoke Clear I can't
see
anything is she on a Channel Nikki back
up a few Fe we can help you
out come on buddy we want to get you
here we want to get you down from
there us that at you got to go back
Nikki we lost visual back
up on you got any weapons on you they
can keep going back you can't
breathe help me your
hand he said let's do it come on it yeah
I can't see him though no like just in
case that they're going to go hands on
he's going to
fight hey guys just be advised he said
let's do it so he may
fight Hey listen to
me I need you to put your hands up above
your head ask him if we bring come to us
I have no idea hey name do you want our
help do you want us to come get
you Dempsey
dempy
shit the get down he's ready he just
want to fight in his
pants
lower the deck lower the
deck come to the for come to the
for I can't see
him careful all right he's up got a
rifle up y cover
low just hold hold cover hold
cover doc dog come here Barry Barry
Barry come to
me
[Music]
shirway open your mouth are you having
trouble
breathing now I don't think he's going
to Pardon you after
this shot one of my
deputies okay let these guys work make
sure we have all our tools all our
equipment is uh Laro that's your first
name what's his first
name HTO okay all right uh so you've
been have you gotten in trouble for
driving without a license
before like you've been driving for a
while yes yeah and you know that you
shouldn't be
driving anything on the other guys no I
don't know how I feel about front
passenger so has the first time you did
like RB Venture PES whatever and I
couldn't understand what he wrote cuz
scratched it well no um before he
scratched it just it didn't look like
correct word I got that
wrongar
Lar
November November
October October yeah no it's RV B vura
okay and his date of birth can you
confirm with him is October 4
1993 yes
correct what is
Ito
oober okay so he said it is um February
the 4st
1993 okay so where did he get October
from no not really I said February the
4th and I'm not sure why he's laughing
there's nothing funny right
now
I'm sorry
but okay well we're going to go ahead
and uh contact Ice real quick and just
make sure you're not wanted by them you
giving me two different date of birth is
making me suspicious can you let him
know that please all right he gave me
the October and then he said he was
February so well I heard what he told
her he definitely said I K bra yeah
that's what then he say no he didn't so
I'm going to do a roadside iceing qu on
him real quick cuz when I mentioned ice
he all of a sudden got like super weird
so I'm going go ahead and see that all
right so you're going to you're being
arrested you're being arrested okay for
no driver's license okay okay can't be
doing that man and you've been you've
been warned about it
[Music]
before
you on yep both new um yeah and got
one
got put your
arm still
work
let's just confirm it but
34 really
yeah look at those 23 24 status
check thought you didn't have any
ID you forgot yeah me
soas was not
vour oh
92 not
[Music]